what i want to explore in this video is
given some length of string or line or
some line segment right here b can i set
up an a so that the ratio of a to b so
that the ratio of a to b
is equal to the the ratio of the sum of
these two to the longer side so it's
equal to the ratio of a plus b
to a so i want to sit and think about
this a little bit i want to see is can i
construct some a that's on this ratio
this perfect ratio that i'm i'm somehow
referring to right here so that the
ratio of the longer side to the shorter
side is equal to the ratio of the whole
thing
to the longer side and let's just assume
that we can find a ratio like that and
we'll call it we'll call it phi we'll
use the greek letter phi for that ratio
over there so let's see what we can what
we can learn about this special ratio
phi
well if phi is equal to a over b which
is equal to a plus b over a we know that
a plus b over a is the same thing as
a over a
plus b over a
a over a is just 1
a over a is just 1 and b over a is just
the inverse of this statement right over
here so b over a this thing right here
over here is phi so b over a is going to
be 1 over phi
this is going to be 1 over 5. so this is
interesting we've now set up a number
which is we're going to call this
special ratio
phi
phi is equal to
is equal to one plus
one over phi
well just that is kind of a neat
statement right over there first of all
you could if you subtract one from both
sides of this you get phi
minus 1 is equal to its inverse that
seems to be a pretty neat property of
any number that if i just subtract 1
from it i get its multiplicative inverse
and so that already that seems kind of
intriguing but even this statement over
here is kind of interesting because you
we've defined phi in terms of 1 plus 1
over phi so we can actually think of it
this way
we could say that phi
we could say that phi is equal to 1 plus
1 over phi but instead of writing five
we say wait wait phi is just one plus
one over
one plus one over instead of saying phi
i could say well
that's just one plus one over
and i could just write phi again or i
could just keep on going i could just
keep on going like this forever i could
say that's 1 over 1 plus 1 over and just
keep on going on and on and on forever
and this is a recursive definition of a
function where a func
or a recursive definition of a variable
where it's defined in terms of itself
but even this seems like a pretty neat
property but we want to get a little bit
further into it we actually eventually
want to figure out what phi is what is
the value of phi this weird number this
weird ratio that we're beginning to
explore
so let's see if we can turn it into a
quadratic equation that we can solve
using fairly traditional methods
and the easiest way to do that is to
multiply both sides of this equation by
phi and then you get phi squared phi
squared let me write a little bit
different
phi squared
plus or phi squared is equal to phi
phi
plus
one phi squared is equal to phi plus one
and then actually i'm going to take a
little bit of a side here because even
this is interesting because then if we
take the square root of both sides of
this you get let me scroll down a little
bit you'll get phi is equal to the
square root of and i'll just switch the
order here square root of 1 plus
the square root of 1 plus phi so once
again we can set up another recursive
definition phi
is equal to the square root
of 1 plus
phi and i could write 5 there but hey
phi is equal to the square root of 1
plus
is equal to the square root of 1 plus
and i could write 5 there but hey phi is
just equal to square root of 1 plus
square root of 1 plus and we could just
keep going on and on like this forever
so even this is neat the same number
that can be expressed this way the same
number where if i just subtract 1 from
it you get its inverse it can also be
expressed in these kind of recursive
square roots under underneath each other
so this is already seeming is starting
to get very very very intriguing but
let's get back to business let's
actually solve for this this magic
number this magic this magic ratio that
we started thinking about and really
from a very simple idea that the ratio
of the longer side to the shorter side
is equal to the ratio of the sum of the
two to the longer side so let's just
solve this as a traditional quadratic
let's get everything on the left-hand
side so we're going to subtract 5 plus 1
from both sides
and we get 5 squared
minus 5
minus 1 is equal to 0 and we can solve
for phi now using the quadratic formula
which we've proven in other videos you
can prove using completing the square
but the quadratic formula you say
negative b negative negative b is the
coefficient on this term right here so
let me just write down a is equal to 1
that's the coefficient on this term b is
equal to negative 1 that's the
coefficient on this term c is equal to
negative 1. that's the coefficient or
it's really the constant term right over
there
so the solutions to this
phi and we're actually only going to
care about the positive solution because
we're thinking about a positive both of
when we go to our original problem here
we're assuming that these are both
positive distances so we care about a
positive value right over here
we get phi is equal to
do it in orange negative b well negative
negative one is one plus or minus the
square root of
b squared b squared is going to be one
minus four ac a is 1 c is negative 1. so
negative 4 times negative 1 is positive
4. so 1
1 plus 4
all of that over 2a so a is 1. so all of
that over 2. so phi is equal to 1. and
once again we only care about the
positive solution here this is going to
be the square root of 5. if you have 1
minus the square root of 5 you're going
to get a negative in the numerator so we
only care about the positive solution
1 plus the square root of 5 over 2. so
this seems like a pretty pretty
interesting interesting number let's
actually take a calculator out and see
if we can get the first the first few
places of of this magic number phi so
let me get my calculator out
and let's just actually evaluate it and
you might recognize that square root of
5 is an irrational number and so this
actually this whole thing is going to be
an irrational number but i'll prove that
in another video which means it never
repeats it goes on and on and on forever
but let's actually evaluate it so it's 1
plus the square root of 5
1 plus the square root of 5 divided by
2.
so this is 1.6180339
so let me put that aside let me put that
aside
let me write it down
and this is where it starts to get
really interesting and mysterious so
this number right over here is
1.618033988
and it just keeps on going on and on and
on keeps on never terminating never
repeating so that by itself hey this is
cool number it's it's this ratio that
has all of these neat properties which
are pretty crazy any way that you
express it
but what's really neat is if we revisit
this thing right over here because what
is 1 over phi gonna be
so 1 over phi
1 over
1 over phi which we sometimes denote
with a capital phi
with a capital phi we already know 1
over 5 is just 5 minus 1. so we actually
can do this in our heads 1 over this is
just going to be
0.618033988 i don't know there's just
something wacky about that that the
inverse of the number is really just the
decimals left over after you get rid of
the one that by itself is kind of a
crazy idea but it gets even crazier
because this number is showing up
everywhere and as
you might imagine from the title of this
video this phi right over here this is
called the golden ratio
this is the golden ratio and it shows up
everywhere
golden ratio
it shows up in art it shows up in music
it shows up in nature
and just to get an idea of where it
shows up in nature it shows up in very
pure ideas so if i were to just draw if
i were to draw a perfect star if i were
to just draw a regular star like this
let me just draw it like this i'll draw
it right over here
so this is just a regular star all the
lengths are equal all the
so i want to draw a little bit better
than that
so if i just draw a star like this right
over here or sometimes this would be
called a pentagram some amazing things
start to happen here
the ratio of the ratio of this pink side
to this blue length right over here
that's the golden ratio the ratio of
this magenta
to this pink is the golden ratio as it
should by definition now the ratio of
the magenta to this
to this orange is also the golden ratio
it just keeps on showing up in a ton of
different ways when you look at a
pentagram like this if you look at
something like a pentagon
a regular pentagon where all the angles
are the same and all the sides are the
same
a regular pentagon if you take any of
the diagonals of a regular of a regular
pentagon so right over here so if you
take this diagonal right over here the
ratio of this green side to and when i'm
talking about the diagonals ones that
actually aren't one of the edges the
ratio of any of the diagonals to any of
the size is once again this golden ratio
so it keeps showing up on and on and on
and we can do interesting things with
the golden ratio let's say that we had a
rectangle where the ratio of the width
to the height is the golden ratio so
let's try that out
let's try that out so let's say that
this is
its height
this is its width and that the ratio
so let's call this a let's call this b
and the ratio of a to b is equal to phi
is that 1.61
so on and so forth let me scroll down a
little bit
so that is going to be equal to phi so
that's that's you know maybe that's
something interesting to do maybe that's
a nice looking rectangle of some sort
but let me put out a square here so let
me put let me separate this into a b by
b square
so this is a b by b square right over
here
and then actually let me do a little bit
let me draw it a little bit differently
this rectangle actually isn't exactly
the way i would want to draw it so the
ratio might look a little bit like this
so the ratio of the width
to the length or the width of the height
is going to be the golden ratio so a
over b
a over b is going to be that golden
ratio and let me separate a little b by
b square over here
a little b by b square
so this has width b as well and so this
distance right over here is going to be
is going to be a minus b so now it is a
b
by a minus b square
so we have a or actually i should say we
have a b by b square right over here
this is b by b and then we're left with
a b by a minus b rectangle now wouldn't
it be cool if this is also if this
this was also the golden ratio and so
let's try it out let's find the ratio of
b to a minus b so the ratio of b to a
minus b well that's going to be equal to
1 over the ratio of a minus b
to b i just took the reciprocal of this
right over here and this is just going
to be equal to 1 over
a over b let me write this a over b
minus 1. right i just rewrote this right
there and that's just going to be equal
to 1 over
phi the ratio of a to b we said by
definition was phi
phi minus
but what is phi minus one well five
minus one is one over phi it's this cool
number this is equal to one over one
over one over phi which is once again
just equal to five so once again the
ratio of this smaller rectangle of its
height to its width is once again this
golden ratio this number that keeps
showing up and then we can do the same
thing again we could separate this into
an a a minus b by a minus b square
just like that and then we'll have
another golden rectangle sometimes it's
called right over there and then we
could separate that into a square and
another
golden rectangle and then we could
separate that into a square and then
another golden rectangle
and then another golden rectangle
actually let me do it like this this
would be better
so let me separate
so let me do the square up here
so this is an a minus b by a minus b
square and then we have another golden
rectangle right over here i could put a
square right in there then we'll have
another golden rectangle then we could
put another square right over there you
have another golden rectangle i think
you see where this is going another
square another golden rectangle which by
itself starts to create a cool design
that we can keep kind of circling in and
in and in and then if we actually draw
an arc here something kind of cool
happens
if we have an arc that kind of traces
these things out
we have something a pattern that you
might have seen
many times before and that pattern does
not look too different than what you
might see in something like a nod is a
nautilus shell and it shows up all over
the place in nature and that makes sense
because just the way cells construct
themselves it kind of makes sense to be
the same at different scales and the
ratio from one scale to the next is
maybe the same as kind of the
constituent ratios
this right here and it shows up all over
art a lot of leonardo da vinci's
paintings he never
not explicitly stated it but and there's
a lot of interesting ratios in them but
salvador dali this painting right here
the sacrament of the last supper he
explicitly used the golden ratio so the
the actual ratio for of the width to the
height is the golden ratio so this is a
golden rectangle and also there's all
sorts of ratios and i'll invite you to
explore it the ratio of the different
parts of the tables to where it sits in
the painting there's the golden ratio
shows up a ton in this painting and then
he does have the pentagons over here and
we know that the ratio of the diagonal
of the pentagon to the size of the
pentagon or also the golden ratio
and so he just thought it was a really
cool thing and there's all sorts of neat
things that if you find you know where
these two guys that are bowing down are
if you draw that line right over here
this is the golden ratio the ratio of
this length right over here to that
length over there once again the golden
ratio just keeps showing up in this
painting so it's a really really really
cool thing and i really encourage you to
explore this
further because it's it's kind of
exciting